The definition of the
conditional PDF is very simple.
It is just this formula, which
is analogous to the one for
the discrete case.
In all respects--
mathematical and intuitive--
it is very similar to
the conditional PMF.
Even so, developing a solid
grasp of this concept does
take some further thinking,
so we will now make some
observations that should be
helpful in this respect.
The first and obvious
observation is that the
conditional PDF is
non-negative.
It's defined when the
denominator is positive, the
numerator is a non-negative
quantity, so it's always a
non-negative quantity.
A more interesting observation
is that for any given value of
little y, the conditional
PDF looks like a slice
of the joint PDF.
Indeed, if you fix the value
of little y, then the
denominator in this definition
is a constant, and we have a
function that varies with x the
same way that the joint
PDF varies with x.
Pictorially, let us consider
this particular joint PDF, and
let this be the x-axis and
let that be the y-axis.
If we fix a certain value of y,
if we condition on Y having
taken this particular value so
that our universe is now this
particular line, on that
universe the value of the
denominator in this definition
is a constant, and the
conditional PDF is going to vary
according to the height
of the joint on that
particular conditional universe.
So the height of the joint, if
we trace it, is one of those
curves up here, and [then]
goes down.
So it is really a slice taken
out of the joint PDF.
If we condition on a different
y, we get a different slice of
the joint PDF, and so on.
Actually, the conditional
is not exactly
the same as the slice.
We also have this term on the
denominator that serves as a
scaling factor.
It turns out that this scaling
factor is exactly what we need
for the conditional PDF, given
a specific value of little y,
to integrate to 1.
Indeed, if we fix little y and
take the integral over all
x's, using the definition, and
because this term is a
constant and does not involve
x, we only need to integrate
the numerator.
And we recognize that the
numerator corresponds to our
earlier formula for the marginal
distribution--
the marginal PDF of Y. From
the joint, this is how we
recover the marginal PDF of Y.
So the numerator turns out
to be the same as the
denominator, and so
we get a ratio 1.
Therefore, the conditional PDF
for a given value of the
random variable Y behaves
in all respects
like an ordinary PDF.
It is non-negative and
it integrates to 1.
A last observation is that we
can take this definition and
move the denominator to the
other side to obtain this
formula, which has the
familiar form of the
multiplication rule.
The probability of two events
happening is the probability
of the first times the
probability of the second
given the first, except that
here we're not really dealing
with probabilities, we're
dealing with densities.
By symmetry, a similar formula
must also be true when we
interchange the roles of X
and Y. So, algebraically,
everything is similar to what
we have seen for the case of
discrete random variables.
It's the same form of the
multiplication rule, although
the interpretation is a bit
different because densities
are not probabilities.